[Musique]
j'ai rencontré shawn murphy alors qu'il
n'avait que 14 ans
c'était un jeune homme extraordinaire
c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
croyez-moi l'autisme
des difficultés à communiquer à utiliser
le langage et les concepts abstraits
[Applaudissements]
ces caractéristiques s'applique-t-elle à
un chirurgien
il respire lui avait sauvé la vie
je suis le dr shawn murphy
il fait preuve d'aptitudes exceptionnel
voit les choses avec un regard différent
[Musique]
vous aviez raison la première fois que
vous m'avez vous avez été mes chantiers
maintenant vous voulez être mon ami quel
moment vous faisiez semblant
il souffre d'un déficit important
aujourd'hui un enfant est en vie grâce à
ce déficit et demain un autre mort à
part sa formule
en faisant le choix d'engager should
nous redonnerons de l'espoir à ceux qui
souffrent d'un handicap et nous leur
montrerons que ce que l'on considère
comme un handicap dont on n'est pas
inquiets sont eux aussi tenter leur
chance
surtout n'oublie jamais que fait le
cerveau de la famille tu peux faire ce
que tu veux
good doctor la nouvelle série événement
mardi 28 août à 21h sur tf1